Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
I'm still in San Francisco.
I was hanging out with Jake from the Key of
Awesome, but he just left to go to the
Big Sur,
so yeah, I'm alone hanging out with some
art and uhm,
well, doing my laundry. But it's okay, because I did
some research and found some things you
can do
online now guys. As a bonus we've got a
special guest coming up,
who helped me do some research this week.
Rinry from RinryGameGame. She does
really great video game history
episodes that are quite Vsauce-y.
Let's have some fun.
First things first, Cat Mario
is so difficult it's hilarious.
But Class 3 Outbreak.com
lets you create and play zombie warfare maps anywhere
in the world, even your own backyard,
using Google Maps.
qKirbyp recommended Draw a stick man,
as did a lot of you. Why?
Because this game is super creative.
You draw your own character
and the game animates them.
You have to draw items and solutions to
get them through the story.
Now, when you finish, celebrate like
weeMAN1300 by doing
the Ugly Dance.com.
You can upload your own photo here,
give yourself some real time moves and
even share your dancing self with a
unique
URL. As you know, I've been traveling and
it's been difficult
for me to research the DONGs that
you guys deserve. But luckily,
Rinry from RinryGameGame,
right here on YouTube, whose channel
I love, has come in to save the day.
Here's an added bonus.
Rinry has the cutest voice on YouTube.
Don't believe me?
Well, guess what, she's right behind me.
Hey Rinry, how do you doing?
Hey Michael, I'm Rinry.
I'm not gonna say much
right now, because my voice hurts, it's broken.
Fortunately
for you guys I recorded
the voice-over couple of days ago.
Awesome. Now here's the part
that's really mind-blowing though.
If you hear her voice, I'm the exact same age
as her. Yeah, can you believe that?
Maybe someday I'll do an episode on aging
and free radicals and whatnot, but in the
meantime, Rinry, give us some DONGs.
Here they are.
Just like the NES, the
Internet has provided us with a wealth
of side-scrollers. Parasites gives the life of
parasitic creature
the side-scrolling treatment. There are colorful
landscapes, funny looking creatures
and so much jumping to be done.
Thank you, sadlyzombiebait.
Discover every pixel, The Small World, in
a side-scrolling adventure sent in by
louswebsite.
Five small worlds to uncover and just one
small jumping stick to do it.
If you've been typing all day and just wanna
relax those aching fingers,
sit back with Wonderputt.
This mini putt course builds
itself as you play and all you have to
do is click and drag that mouse to
guide the ball past maze like
obstacles.
Guide the blue ball to the red ball
in 3D maze, the rotating puzzler sent in
by LyricQueen1231.
Neon Maze is a cop above colors for you
to contest as quickly as possible.
Guide your color coordinated buddy with your
mouse to beat each level.
Just not interested in winning anymore?
You can't win in Triangulate,
but you may get addicted to manipulating
triangle, just like myself and
alltehstuffs did.
Man In the Dark has an
unlikely addiction to your mouse. He'll follow your
cursor around the window
and his body can become almost elastic in
need to keep up with it.
Did you think this man was alone in the dark?
Click again.
If you just don't feel like focusing on
what you're doing
the Disagreeing Internet will help.
The way it refuses to stay still will guarantee a
lack of focus on any task.
The Hacker Typer will allow you to
appear to be intensely focused on
hacking
while actually typing whatever gibberish
you want.
Just press F11 to full screen the
page and pretend to hack like a pro.
Thank you so much for doing that Rinry.
I didn't have enough time this week to
research as many DONGs as I wanted to,
but you came through in the clutch
and that makes you saucy in my book.
Click here to check out her channel
and maybe later on do something
different for a change.
Do nothing for two minutes.com
That's right. You win by doing nothing.
As soon as you do something, you loose.
It's kind of a fun concept, so check that one out.
Subscribe to Vsauce if you haven't
already.
And as always,
thanks for watching.